Hogwarts Legacy has absolutely shattered
even wb's expectations for the game
selling 256 percent more than expected
and earning more than 850 million
dollars oh and that's just in its first
two weeks on the market this all
according to a LinkedIn update from
Aryan Darby a senior brand and marketing
manager at WB Games the update was
originally discovered by a Twitter user
and then later reported on by Insider
gaming the last sales numbers we saw for
Hogwarts Legacy had it at more than 12
million units sold during its first two
weeks but we could be hearing a more
updated sales number very soon Insider
gaming reports that we could hear more
at the company's upcoming stockholder
meeting which is set to take place on
May 8th what's amazing is that Hogwarts
Legacy has yet to release on PS4 Xbox
One and the still massively popular
Nintendo switch in fact
gamesindustry.biz even reported that
Hogwarts Legacy has been so successful
that it's one of the biggest reasons
that q1 2023 total sales of video games
actually outsold q1 2022 and that's even
considering that 2022 had titles like
Eldon ring and Horizon forbidden West
now even if you've already played
Hogwarts Legacy this is a really big
deal and here's why first off if you're
a fan of the work that Avalanche
software has done here this is an
incredibly huge win for them and I'm
sure that talks are already ongoing
about their next project and the reason
something like this is such a big deal
in the games industry is because not
only do you have a critical success here
with reviewers scoring this game very
highly but you also have a commercial
success which unfortunately at the end
of the day if a game doesn't make money
doesn't matter how many people say they
like it if it's not making money it
probably won't last very long but this
with Hogwarts Legacy doing so well
Avalanche software is now in an
incredibly advantageous position to
where I would think they are going to
have a huge say in their next project
now if you've been following the game
for a while then you'll already know
that game director Alan 2 has basically
said they want to do more in this world
we have to go back a little bit but
right after that first Sony state of
play there was also an accompanying
PlayStation blog post and just in case
you've forgotten here's the exact line
from Alan here this is at the very end
of his quote it says with your continued
support we hope to explore even more in
the future by this point it should be
incredibly clear to everyone just how
passionate and excited Avalanche was
about this project so while I have no
doubt that WB could have them tackle a
number of different IP and they would do
a fantastic job with it I think they've
definitely proven that my strong hunch
is that Avalanche will want to do more
in the Wizarding World whether it's
Hogwarts Legacy 2 or whether they
completely reset and have a totally new
idea also the last we heard when it
comes to DLC is that they had no current
plans for DLC but I personally would be
very very shocked if there is not DLC
eventually for this game we just don't
know when with the incredible critical
success and the incredible commercial
success I think DLC is just a matter of
time and also it's a question of how big
is it going to be you also have the fact
that they are continuing to engage with
the community Chandler Wood Community
manager has been doing these bi-weekly
Legacy lives over on Twitch and speaking
of those Legacy live updates if you
missed the most recent one they actually
confirmed that the Merlin cloak twitch
drop will return possibly with some new
drops as well now if you're not familiar
with twitch drops these are something
that you log into your Twitch account
and then you connect it to the WB
account and then you can actually unlock
things in game for free they're normally
cosmetic items and the most popular one
last time was the Merlin cloak as far as
a time frame for when we may see those
new drops they didn't outright confirm
anything but I think it's highly likely
to be around the launch of the PS4 and
Xbox One versions of the game which is
still set for May 5th 2023. now if
you're curious about my thoughts on the
game and what I would like to see in
terms of DLC and a sequel well we did an
absolutely massive live stream here on
the channel over four hours long if
that's your thing you can check it out
on the right side of your screen now
jump around with the time stamps and let
me know in the comments below what you
guys think what you'd like to see in
terms of DLC and the future of Hogwarts
Legacy big shout out and thank you to
all of our channel members and as always
guys thank you all so much for watching
I'll talk to you again soon